storm warnings are still in effect but
appears Hamburg has seen the worst the
high winds are gradually weakening but
not before sava whipped up the second
highest recorded tidal surge ever to hit
Hamburg only a major storm in the 1970s
pushed waters higher the city's famous
fish market was under water for several
hours up to six meters higher than
normal in some places as ocean swells
pushed inland shipping traffic was also
disrupted at Germany's largest container
seaport determined at the terminal
stopped working I can't operate a
container terminal with its giant
bridges in the face of wind speeds this
high the storm hit northern Germany
packing wind speeds up to 150 kilometers
an hour
despite its severity Savin left behind
less damage than feared just a few weeks
ago a storm caught christian court
authorities off-guard
so they made sure locals were properly
prepared this time around storms impact
is never predictable so we were all
anxious we're now relieved it might have
been much worse
a pig unearthed some tourists have
already returned to the baltic sea shore
the kite surfers taking advantage of
some serious swells delays in shipping
cost money but the shipping companies
and the port operators have already
taken those costs into account the most
important thing is to prevent flood
damage to the port itself if that
happens shipping operations could be
delayed by weeks instead of days